[Music]  thank you  what's your backup plan if the bridge  closes and you experience Bad Blood  flooding we would definitely try to get  the higher ground we have friends that  are just you know the other side of the  neighborhood we could get to and also  kayaks and powder forms case if we get  in big trouble the winds aren't the  super dangerous part of this it's going  to be watery  [Music]  and what's your biggest concern just  helping folks get out of Harm's Way and  then ensuring that we have the ability  to get back in here as quickly as  possible and we gain some normalcy we  want everybody back in their home safely  as quickly as possible after this  honeymoon got canceled too yeah  thank you  how stressful is that oh I had a  meltdown  but how do you feel now awesome yeah I  mean I think we still accomplish  everything that we set out to do we have  the people that we love I can't I can't  make any complaints about it it's a  wedding you'll never forget